(speaking foreign language)
- Hear that?
That is a military code
of the Choctaw nation.
Can't understand it?
Neither could the Germans.
(orchestral music)
Our story starts on the Western
front during Word War I.
The Allies are in trouble.
The Germans have tapped their phone lines
and deciphered their codes.
As the Allies struggled
to find a solution,
one captain overheard
two of his Native
American Choctaw soldiers
speaking their mother tongue.
When the captain
overheard the two soldiers
speaking their native language--
- [Nuchi] They probably thought
they were in really big trouble.
- That's Nuchi Nashoba.
- Hi there.
- [Narrator] Great-granddaughter of one
of those two soldiers
and president of the Choctaw
Code Talkers Association.
Around this time, if a Choctaw were caught
speaking the language, they were liable
to be sent away to a reeducation program.
But the captain, he had a different idea.
- [Nuchi] If I can't
understand what they're saying,
perhaps the Germans won't understand
what they're saying.
- [Narrator] The U.S.
military began transmitting
technical messages in Choctaw, and,
unsurprisingly, the Germans
could not break the code.
Not all military terms had a
direct Choctaw translation.
- [Nuchi] Machine gun
(speaking foreign language)
was little gun shoot fast.
Ammunition
(speaking foreign language)
was arrows.
And gas
(speaking foreign language)
was bad air.
- [Narrator] And due at least in part
to the Choctaw code talkers
and their neologisms,
the war ended soon thereafter.
- [Nuchi] When you look at
how ironic it is for
the government to say you
can't speak your language,
but yet they used them
to help win World War I.
That's pretty amazing to me.
(light music)
(cheering)
(electronic music)